Let's go next to our caller from the eight
three two area code caller from eight three
two.
What's your name and where are you calling
from?
They sent me.
Yes, it is.
Oh, hi, David.
Big fan.
Thank.
My name is Luis Castillo Trailers.
Kathy, I just have a question.
Yeah, I've noticed in the press briefings.
The presidential press briefings.
Yeah, I was I was just wondering if there
are any progressive journalists in those press
briefings.
Right.
Because I know I mean, I know I don't know
what network they're from, but while they
do see the network they're from.
But I was just wondering, do you know of any
of them if there any journalists like from
a progressive news network there?
Well, it depends on what you call progressive.
I mean, the journalists that are there are
not at least supposed to be opinion people
the way and people obviously are right wing
loons.
There are people who say, oh, yeah, and CBS
are left wing.
But of course, the people that are there,
like, you know, Caitlin Collins is there for
CNN.
I don't know her personal politics.
I know adversarial relationships exists between
CNN and and the Trump administration right
now.
But I don't know the politics of all the people
in the room because they're not they're really
supposed to be there as reporters, not as
politically biased individuals.
Oh, I see, so, so.
OK.
So, like the audience would be like the exception,
I guess, to the rule, because I noticed that
it seemed to carry this young lady and she
doesn't even sit around.
Yeah, she's absolutely bonkers.
She's.
Her name is Chanel Reon Sheet.
She doesn't even understand the questions
she's asking.
She gets this vacuous look in her eyes where
she like she has an idea of a question.
And I don't know if she has it written down,
but you can tell she's having trouble passing
the grammar of her own question in her mind,
like she doesn't even know what she's saying.
It's all very, very weird.
But for the most part, what you have is, you
know, like Reuters has a reporter there, the
Associated Press.
These are people who obviously they have personal
political views, but they're not really supposed
to be part of their role as as part of the
White House press corps.
Oh, OK.
Would you ever kill someone like you, ever
considered opinion that you considered to
be in that room?
I can't.
I don't know.
I can't imagine that they would ever grant
me a God, grant me a press pass loose.
I mean, I'll let you go.
Okay, great.
Your audio is a bit problematic, but I think
I'm the last person that is going to be allowed
into the press room.
And certainly if I were, I don't think I'd
be allowed to to ask a question.
Let's go to what a caller from the nine five
four area code who's calling today from nine
five.
David, this is Derek in Tallahassee.
Hey, Derek, what's going on?
I love Florida.
You are in the epicenter of Corona virus.
That's right.
Give me one second.
OK.
Take your time.
Lots going on there.
Sounds like a running mate.
Yes, sir.
So, yeah, it's getting pretty bad here.
But wanted to hear your take on the one of
these shooting with a Rashad Brooks and whether
the charges are justified.
Listen, I don't.
I don't know.
I don't know it.
My position is the same as with the George
Floyd case, which is I don't know what the
right charges are.
We have a system.
I'm not a prosecutor.
I'm not a lawyer.
I can look at stuff and sort of say what happened
was wrong.
But in terms of the charges, there's strategy
that goes into charges.
There's evidentiary considerations.
I don't know what the right charges are.
And that's similar to what I said in terms
of the charges against Derrick Schavan and
the other officers.
I think, you know, you you really only know
in retrospect whether the charges were the
right charges.
And it has to do with the evidence.
It has to do with a lot of different things.
I just don't know the answer.
So you think it was too quick for the Atlanta
to bring charges?
I think it was just like a day and a half.
They had like a special investigation or something.
I really just don't know.
Well, all of these things are it's speculation
from the outside.
Sometimes investigations happen very quickly.
Sometimes they don't.
I think we're just not going to know until
more time goes by.
Well, my take on it.
Yeah, I think this is one that upsets people
and it's very gray zone.
You know, the media was saying that he was
sleeping well.
Really, he was drunk.
The media said he was unarmed.
But, I mean, he stole the cop's taser, fired
at the cop.
And then the media said he was nonviolent
before arresting him.
Have you talked to any families who lost a
life to you?
Why?
I'm sure they'll say that's a violent crime.
So you're saying that the fact that he was
potentially going to drive drunk is an act
of violence?
In a sense, of course.
Yeah, I don't think that's actually going
to that's that's a debate that is not unique
to this case.
I don't believe that's actually going to be
the determining factor.
The guy was running away.
He wasn't driving away.
So the fact that we can debate whether driving
drunk is a violent act I don't think is going
to play a big role in what ultimately happens.
No.
Yeah, I appreciate it.
All right, my friend.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Let's go to a break.
That's all the time I have for today.
As always, I apologize.
I was not able to get to everybody, but we
will take calls again.